Hello and welcome to today's episode of clustered.
This is episode 14, and I have two
fantastic guests and two very broken clusters
for us to fix today.
Before we get started, there's just a little
bit of housekeeping.
First and foremost, if you haven't pressed that
subscribe button,
you can do that now.
Also remember to thumbs up slash like the
video. This will help other people find it.
It's always a good thing.
And if you wish, you can now join
the Rawkode Academy at a sandbox level for
a very tiny tiny nominal fee, which will
get you some cool emojis and private live
streams coming up soon.
Today,
we have
Adrian and Sid joining us.
We have both prepared one one
broken cluster each and will join me as
we attempt to pair and fix the others.
Hi there, Adrian. Hi there, Sid. How are
you both today?
Doing well.
Yeah. Doing just fine. It's a bit warm,
but
It was not a problem I have in
Scotland today. It's been raining and windy all
day. One second. I have to take a
phone call.
Please don't put up. Sorry. Yeah.
Alright. Well, Aaron takes the phone call. Sid,
do you wanna introduce yourself and tell us
a little bit about you, please? Sure.
My name is Sid Palace. I am a
DevOps consultant. I split time between helping startups
improve their DevOps and cloud infrastructure setups and
also making content for my YouTube channel and
my blog. So I have a YouTube channel
called DevOps Directive where I cover
a variety of topics from Docker to Kubernetes
and all sorts of things. So go check
that out if you have time. Most of
my Kubernetes experience is with managed clusters. So
depending where Arion breaks things,
that could be useful or it could be
completely worthless.
So we will find out once once we
start poking around.
Nice. Yeah. I definitely encourage people to check
out the dev ops directive. It's a fantastic
YouTube channel. Lots of great content there.
Hello,
Adi. Would you like to give us a
quick introduction if you're alright sir? And I
have we'll get started.
Yeah. Sure. So I'm
Arian. I in my spare time, I work
on NextOS,
which is a declarative
operating system, which has a lot of
cutting points with Kubernetes because you all like
declarative and immutable things as well.
And
for work, I work at Wire.
We do end to end encrypted chat and
video communication,
and I
maintain Kubernetes clusters here and do operations
and break
things very often as well.
Occasionally, also write some code, but lately, not
so much.
Yeah. That's a quick introduction of myself, I
would say.
Yeah. Awesome. Thank you very much both of
you for for sharing. So
we are gonna start today with cluster 31.
Sid, that means you and I are up
first.
I have enabled the head We
can see teleport, which is our pairing tool
of choice.
I will open a session here. Sid, if
you can do me a favor.
Once you're in, just type some sort of
echo hello to let me know that you're
there. We should also see a nice little
to show up here.
Adrian, you can just sit and watch and
prepare the laughter. If you got a beer,
you actually have a beer. Yeah. I told
you I would get a beer.
I am
betterly unprepared and jealous, but
enjoy it, mate. Okay.
So I will do a little bit of
setup first. These are QVDM clusters. That means
our Okay.
Configuration
lives here.
I will alias k to keep control, otherwise
you will just be watching me type k
and that failing many many times.
And Seth, I will give you the honors
of running on the first command to see
if we have any sort of API server
available to us.
Hey. We did. Look at that. Thank you
for help.
Didn't break everything.
So I'm proud of myself.
Okay.
The API server is good. So let me
clarify
the the objective then when we have an
API server. Right? It's sometimes it can be
a little bit fussy. Our objective now can
be a little bit confusing. Our objective now
is to make sure that our clustered and
postgres squeal pods are running and happy,
and also
to be able to upgrade our cluster pod
from v one to v two.
That is our objective.
Alright. So you have run a get pods
and we can already see
Postgres is definitely not happy
And
And and clustered has restarted a few times.
It has. Yes.
Alright.
Let's check out
what's going on with Postgres.
Okay.
So we have a taint on it that
it won't tolerate.
Okay. So yeah, it's unable to be scheduled
right now. It looks like our worker node
has memory pressure and
obviously we don't tolerate running on the control
blend mode.
Yep. Yep.
What are you thinking? What do we need
to look at here?
Yeah. I was just gonna scroll through this
config and see
see what we've got.
Well, I'm curious about this memory pressure label
on the node.
Yeah. Should we describe the node and see
what that looks like? Yeah. Good show. I
think that's a good idea. What
I've got in my head here is that
Adrian can just be cruel and just add
either label to mess with us or he's
maybe actually
screwed with the memory available to the Yeah.
To the kubelet.
I see that smirk in your face there.
I have a very bad poker face. I
wish I turned off the webcam.
There
we go. Look at that.
Okay. Eviction threshold met. Attempting to reclaim memory.
I think we're just gonna have to jump
on to that worker notes.
Yep.
In the memory here, nice big number, which
is what I wanna see. So
I will open a session on the worker.
Just feel free to jump into it, let
me know when you're there.
Okay. And then we'll start to look around
and see what's happening.
What kind of beer you got?
We got wait.
No. A roadhouse,
which is a pilsner.
I like it a lot.
From the the black woods in Germany.
Ah, nice. Nice German beer.
Okay.
I'm
getting a oh, hold on.
I had a a background window open with
the YouTube videos. I started getting a delayed
loop, but now I'm good.
I've
done I've done that so many times.
Alright.
Let's I'm gonna run my my favorite memory
command.
So
this looks good to me, which means so
my thought process here is that
alien has
modify
seems
I don't know. I think he's modified the
system d unit file for the cubelet and
his memory constraint. Is that a lane where
you if you got any other ideas you
wanna throw it?
That seems like a reasonable first
first place to look.
Okay.
Well, there's nothing there.
Or should we cap the unit fail? Get
all the actual what do you call them
in system? Do drop ins or is it
something else?
Yeah, drop ins. Drop ins.
Alright.
So
system control cat kubelet. This should I believe
shows us the entire config and then we
can look for files that could potentially be
have other stuff in it.
Let me know if get any ideas. Otherwise,
I'm just gonna be
looking aimlessly. Poking around.
There is a way, right, when you
can you see the niceness level of a
process of Linux? I think there is.
Like,
let's see.
That's to run a command with a nice
value.
Could be
Alright.
Let's just start looking at the files listed
in this unit.
So we've got
this one. That's the one it's showing us.
won't be the bit strap.
Could be fire lib kubelet config and fire
lib kubelet flags. Those are the two I
think we we're gonna wanna look into.
Are they clean to you?
Yeah.
Config.
And there we go to keep the configuration.
Yeah. Don't think there'll be anything in there.
Hey. Your tongue's dead. I'll sit back. I'll
watch.
Did we just did we describe the node
on
the control plane? We did describe the worker
node. Not on the control plane.
We only did it for the the worker
node. So we could describe that one as
well. Yeah. I wonder, am I over
I mean, he could just have added the
label. He might not have actually done anything
to the memory on the machine. Right?
True. That's worth checking. So should we hop
back to that other
that other one? Yeah. Do you wanna Or
is this one also set up? Oh, no.
Just the just the Okay. So if you
why don't we just do
a Yep. Do wanna just edit the node
and remove the label, see what happens?
Sure. It's a good start.
Come on. Editing the service files is way
too easy. Yeah.
What what was even easier would just be
adding a label.
I keep looking at him to see if
he's gonna give anything away but I've lost
you there.
I'm practicing my poker face.
So Alright. So we do not have
memory constraint label there.
Yeah. Maybe on the worker. Oh, I'm hinting
things again.
Oh, yeah.
But what did you what was your edit
command? Sorry. I missed it.
Oh, no. We're stuck in Vim.
Okay. What? What?
Oh, let me out.
Let me out.
Oh, it's there. You'll need to do q
exclamation mark exclamation mark. Yeah. Otherwise, you'll run
it. Otherwise.
Oh, we looked at the worker. Did we
not?
Oh, no. You edited the control. Yeah. Okay.
That'll be why we couldn't see the label.
Not there?
No.
Here we go. Oh, there's a tint. There
we go.
Yeah. Let's We just remove that entirely? Yeah.
Let's do it.
You can just remove that. Yeah.
Okay. Just bend it.
You
might wanna just create postgres again.
Yeah.
When did that nine seconds So
let's see if that taint magically reappeared.
So how
is that getting added?
So
what if
I I would sort of stuff out all
the time. If you got I don't yeah.
That's a good shit.
So let's also check all namespaces, I guess,
in case he hit it somewhere.
Oh, okay. Have a namespace.
Alright.
We've got a bunch of NGINX pods that
are
getting evicted.
Stop laughing.
Okay. Sorry. No. I'm allowed to laugh. Right?
That's whole point. Yeah. That is the whole
point. Let's
see what what these are doing. We have
this this service.
Let me just try deleting that service and
see what happens.
Alright. The deployment, not the service.
It was kinda nice that the load balancer
service type just works on the
was cool.
Yeah. These clusters are currently running natural l
b, and I'm in the process of migrating
over to.
But yeah.
But I did give you a broken CSI
implementation.
So
There's also I heard that Cilium now has
part of the meta l b code base
integrated.
Yeah. They did some work with DGP. I
saw that announcement last week.
So
let's just
actually, why don't I just delete that whole
namespace?
We we probably don't need it. Yeah. Yeah.
I I don't trust that namespace. I'm I'm
happy for you to blow it away. That's
it.
Arian.
Okay.
Takes a little while. Now let's go back
and try to edit that taint off the
node
in case that pod was adding it back.
It may still be there.
It may still be there. That's true.
It is still there.
Okay.
So
we've we've cleaned up something, but we don't
know what that something was actually doing.
Do you mind if I type for a
moment? I'm just Yeah. Go for it. Curious.
Is that if okay. Yeah. That does look
like Yeah. It it did indeed get get
cleaned up.
Is there something else that could intercept our
node config before it gets
used or after it gets used, I suppose?
Some kind of Yeah. Well Mutating
webhook or
Yeah. Mutating webhooks
are always oh.
I see. Oh, no. I thought we were
getting a broken
API server there.
Damn.
Lots of issues with Rawk.
Yeah. I'm gonna filter that out.
Look how slow it is when I get
pods across all namespaces.
It's like Right. There's probably a lot of
stuff somewhere.
Yep. I was kinda surprised, like, once it
is evicted, that it doesn't clean up that
port reference. Like, it just keeps accumulating.
Let's see.
And what is what is Hubble UI? Is
that just an interface for Cilium? Yeah. It's
a really cool UI that shows you network
traffic across your nodes and services and such.
It's pretty sweet.
I I just wanna see it running. Come
on.
Anything. Show me anything that's running in my
cluster. I don't care about pending an infected
write down.
Okay. So, we got speakers, we got some
Rook stuff, we got our control plane.
I just wanna know, yeah, there's nothing to
Nothing that looks nefarious here of course you
could have swapped out any of these images,
but
that would tell me, I think I like
your idea instead. Let's check for mutating webhooks.
Let's go down that path first before we
start checking the nodes for rogue processes.
Got a tip from Nolan in the chat
as well that there could be a fiction
hard set on the Qubelet.
How do we actually view these? I'm using
webhook configurations.
No resources found.
Only yeah. Cool.
Still no resources found. Okay.
Should we jump back across to the worker?
Sure.
Start looking first. Is there anything else? No.
No.
I think I think that's
that's all I can think of at at
this side of things.
Okay. Because we're our our edit to the
node is going through successfully. So it's not
like a validating webhook could be the case
because otherwise, we'd get an error back if
it was just rejecting it.
Nothing no static pods. So
what happened there?
And that weird reload debug.
I'm just scrolling. Alright. I thought I was
gonna drop out our config.
What do you want to do?
The view the entire config at once or
I did want to view the entire config
at once. Yes. Alright.
I think let let me tell you where
I'm at. Right now, I'm at the stumps,
to be honest. I think we go through
this config file for the kubelet and we
see if there's anything restricting it here. I'm
also curious if he's just been really
cheeky and scaled up a whole bunch of
those
deployments to a stupid number causing the evictions
and
because those have all got requests on them.
Right? I could just be adding up.
All those, like, system and Celeum and Rawk
deployments we We could check the requests
and
on the notes, see if
they are larger than the capacity, for example.
Right?
Yeah.
Yeah. That looks okay.
If
you want hints, you can always
you can have two in total, probably. Don't
know. Go back to you, Pierre. Go away.
I mean, we we could take the the
thing you just gave us and and actually
check those requests on the nodes and see
if if there's more requests than
Yeah. Available.
I mean, the node isn't breaking us wet.
Right? Yeah.
So,
does feel like this is all happening on
the
I didn't see anything in the Kubla config
there. So, yeah. Let's jump back to the
control plane. There has to be something on
the API.
I
need to speak with someone at teleport, that
bugs annoying.
So, where do you wanna check for request?
Of course.
In fact, did
we describe them?
Feeling so scarpered today. Don't know what that
is. We did describe the node. Right? We
did. And there was no
artificial
request or limits on that.
I don't think so.
Yes. We I don't know if we described
the control plan node, but we we described
the working on. Yeah. I think the working
on this
one. So k. So we got the infection
threshold limit here.
It has sufficient memory,
and that's happening a lot.
Trying to reclaim memory from the eviction here.
We can see
that we've actually only got 1% of requests
and 1% of limit.
Yeah.
Well, the vection threshold is
has to be that has to be Kubelay
configuration. Right?
There there is a hint in the Kubelay
config.
There is. Maybe. Yeah. Yes. There there is
something. Because
we're not memory constrained at all.
Which which means that it just feels like
it's kubect config.
Yeah. And it's not the
it's not getting evicted
based on too much memory use. It's just
never getting scheduled. So it's not something in
the Postgres
stateful set config.
Could be something else. But There are also
evicted bots. Right? There's a pending bot, but
some bots are also getting actively evicted.
True. So I
guess we're going back to the worker node
then.
Okay. Do you wanna pop open the Kubelet
config again?
Maybe.
Didn't mean to do that.
He told us there was there might be
a hint in here. Right? There's only 38
lines.
Would there be an easy way to figure
out what KubeADM usually spits out?
Yeah. Could you grab a a healthy config
and then we could diff them maybe or
at least take a look? I think we
can just run to generate
one.
I'm looking at all those zero seconds,
and I'm thinking,
are those a thing or am I making
too much of that at the end?
No. That that that's too much. Those are
there by default. I only I
appended a line to the config.
It's
at the it's it's at the end. Let's
we'll give this a second.
C group driver line?
Yes.
Alright. So we just ask to generate one
and we'll just do a death in there.
We'll see what happens.
Sure.
I I don't know the command.
I should not verify now.
Let's have a look.
But I'm pretty sure we can do a
That would be
there's some way to run the individual faces
or something. Yeah. There is.
I think it's under in it, and then
you can pass in.
Cube ADM diff. Is that a thing?
Somebody says the Cube ADM diff is a
thing. That would be cool.
Is it?
Everything else is alphabetical except for c group
driver. This is
This is a There is a thing.
I just don't remember off the top of
my head. So But this is not a
control plane node. Right? So we need don't
we need to join?
But
And it there we go.
Kube finalize.
Yeah. I think Kube let's start puts in
the bootstrap config, and Kube let's finalize does
the
Did I spell that wrong? Yeah. Alright.
Don't know if that's gonna run it.
Do you want me to tell you the
diff instead?
Yeah. I mean, for the sake of time,
it seems like Yep. And you've already hinted
that it's that last line. We just Yep.
So
yeah. There there there
are two things I changed in this config.
One is I
I am a system d. I love system
d, so I wanted try out the system
d c group driver.
And
I also and also changed the resolve conf
option.
But
so those two I touched. The only two
I touched.
Apart from that, there's a completely vanilla config.
Alright.
Yeah.
But I think the last one is probably
the first one to look at given that
that has more to do with the issues
we're seeing, probably.
Alright. I am going to look up Qubelet
driver
and see what the options are here because
I have no idea.
Apparently, it defaults to system d. Yep.
Oh, there's our Kubernetes minute command.
Yeah. So
Continue. Yeah.
So if that is the default, then you
haven't actually changed it. Right? Unless cluster API
doesn't use the system d c group driver
by default.
Or maybe this is one two one docs.
Is this just a new change?
So the the c group driver there was
already a c group driver line that I
added
It had something else before.
So Mhmm.
Yeah.
So, yeah, maybe check the older version. Yeah.
Yep.
Oh, thanks. Oh, no.
And of course the search goes back to
the latest version.
Alright. Let's copy the bit after the thing
and then come here.
The page doesn't exist.
Darn it.
Kubernetes
component.
K
this is
frustrating.
Why can't I find that page on that
version of the doc?
Okay. Tasks,
administer cluster q b d m.
So
where's that menu bar now?
Right.
Task.
Administer a cluster.
Just step three.
And configure secret. Oh, it's not in the
docs.
No. It's new docs.
Sorry.
Maybe there only used to be one option,
so they didn't say anything about it.
Well, that at least explains
why we're
unable to look this up. Yeah. Well, let's
see if we could just take a look
at this. This wonderful brand new one twenty
one dot, which default to system deep, apparently
prior to that was not the case.
So
c group f s, is that?
Yeah.
Okay. So the c group f s driver.
Yeah. I'm it says here to continue using
that. Good catch that.
Well, we just Yeah. Found some random Stack
Overflow page that mentioned c c group f
s. So we've got two sources that state
that as a potential candidate.
Or should we migrate to the system d
driver following the correct instructions
correctly, which which Adrian did not do. So
Let's
revert to to cgroupfs,
I think.
Yeah. I think that's a good call. Let's
just get it working, and then you can
it in to share what exactly is happening
here. So I'll
I'll do the control plane. Do wanna update
the worker node?
Yep. I just updated on the the worker
node. Alright. Nice. Yeah. I I have a
high level of confidence this might fix it,
but I'm not sure.
Yep. So we need to restart on our
Kiplet.
Alright. Nice.
Alright. I will give you the honors of
running a get pods on our control player.
Let's see if that has helped at all.
I'll pop over
to the chat and I'm sure everyone is
yelling at us.
So no confirmed as zero sort of default.
You know, I fall for these zeros in
the Kubernetes config all the time in default
versus something nefarious.
You mentioned in dev, it doesn't exist. That's
a great idea for a sub command though.
Let's make that happen.
Ben noticed that everything was in alphabetical order
except the secret driver. Yeah. I never thought
of checking that. Very clever.
It looks like we have a new error,
though, at least.
Yeah. We're in unknown territory now, though. I
don't know how to fix it from here
on. So this is
Great.
He he did mention changing that one other
config.
Okay. What's the
resolve conf?
Yeah. But it's not related to the issues
we're seeing now. Okay. So I think that's
just because we've changed it. Right? And we
have running processes probably using the system d
driver.
Yeah. So now there's like two views of
the world. Right?
So I don't know. Maybe we should
restart container d or something on the on
the the
that are running.
What we would have to do is probably
We can cordon and uncordon.
We
Can we check system details status just to
see what processes are running and stuff on
the on the worker?
Well, the control plane is degraded anyway, and
they are the same there. Gotcha.
And if we scroll down a bit,
just see what what stuff is running. There's
a lot of output here. It should show.
So
here is all the containers running. So it
still seems to be using the
system DC group driver. That's why it shows
up nicely here even
though we changed it.
So
Nice. That is a horrible way to break
a cluster.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's think.
I say we make the system d secret
driver work.
How hard can that be? With the the
upgrade path on the
on the docs?
Oh, it's actually telling us to drain the
node
and then restart the kubelet. So
yeah. We can do that.
Alright.
Throw random system d at the cluster and
it breaks. Alright.
Let's I like this comment. Let's stick with
the worker node right now. So let's update
it. Let's set it back to system d.
Yep.
D.
Oop. That means Oh, no. That one doesn't
exist yet.
So
And then we have to drain and or
or we need to Do we need to
restart, or you're do that after?
Do we need to restart the cube load?
Or wanna do that after we drain it?
I guess it yeah. I think with how
fucked that is right now, I don't I
probably it doesn't make I think it would
just restart it for now. It's fine. Yeah.
But after I get notes, and I'm just
gonna drain
Yeah. Our worker.
Okay. It's now being cordoned,
workloads will start to drain off of it.
What we can do now is that we
actually stop the kubelet. We've had the kubelets
only thing running because there's nothing else here.
The daemon sets will be on it. We
can restart those manually.
Did we restart the kubelet already
or not?
We have one. Yeah. But I think when
the I did it before he cordoned it
though, I think. Yeah. Yeah. She wanted to
Hey. Look at this. There is a container
creating now for that.
Oh.
But I think now because we restarted it
again. Oh, it's it's something is running. It's
good. It's running. We have zero
of one ready, though. Yeah. Do you wanna
uncord it or note? Or did you do
that already?
I did not.
But how is it scheduled?
Interesting.
Scheduled onto the control plane?
Oh, wait. I think it did it didn't
actually it complained that it couldn't drain. Look.
Unable to drain. Oh. Oh, but then it
should still be cordoned, right, even if it
didn't drain it? Or
I think if it's We can't delete the
pods with the the storage. Right? So we
could have just sold it to delete the
empty chairs because they're not required.
But
I think we've done enough to get it
back online. Right? That that pod is coming.
That part is coming. Oh. Yeah. It's
it's back. Alright. Let's unload and
Yeah.
Let's let's get a port forward running, see
if we can have our application and try
the update.
Like, all we need to do is get
our app working and then Yeah. If we
get the updates mission accomplished. Right? Exactly. Yeah.
You
can just do a cube control on card
and then the node name.
I don't know the node name. Yeah. I
don't know the node name.
The worker.
I still find it weird that those pods
got scheduled and run
on it. It was cordoned.
We're done.
Okay.
I'll jump over to my local terminal for
the port forward.
Okay. I'm here to set it up on
teleport so that we can just expose it
from the
the UI, but I haven't done it yet.
So,
get pods.
Or forward.
Uh-huh.
No.
Oh, no. There's there's Oh, well, actually,
the daemon sets will need restarted with our
cilium pods. Right?
And so if you wanna do a cue
control get pods on our cilium namespace,
we probably have no networking at all in
our cluster.
Oh, what?
No. I will just throw out my idea
here, which is the one I try not
to recommend anyone try at home, but it's
to do delete pods all on the Selium
namespace. I'm totally okay with that if you
wanna if you wanna But they're
ready. Too current, too ready.
Too up to date, too available.
That's
Let's let's try it.
Never hurts. Oh. Pods dash dash all.
Oh,
that's a very interesting.
Oh, no.
No. It's no. No. It was just in
Cillium. No. It was just in Cillium.
It was just a lot. Just okay. It
was just a lot of
I
only bail if they got the fear. It's
okay.
Alright. What does it get pods look like
by then?
That hasn't returned yet. But
Yeah. We can Yeah.
Just control c. It just usually waits for
the thing to finish. We don't have to.
Okay.
That's
Celeb m one's coming up. Container creating.
Okay. Yeah. I see that's
to look quite healthy.
Yep. Give it a few moment a few
more seconds.
Alright. We got some more things. Coming.
Alright.
So can you do a dash o wide?
What what node are those first two on?
Control play. I don't think did we restart
the kubelet there after updating the config?
On the control plane? Yeah. Not not sure.
Yeah. I don't think I don't think I
I think I updated the config, but I
don't think I restarted the kubelet on the
control plane.
What do I do? So I'll see system
CPR.
Noel in the chat has said that the
docs say this field should not be updated
without fully rebooting the node.
Well I don't read I don't read docs.
That's
otherwise, the clusters don't break.
So the sandbox for those first two pods
will already be created under the the
maybe the wrong
yeah.
I think we may have to delete those
two pods and
try and encourage it to restart again. I'm
not sure. Are they running on the control
plane? Yeah. They are. Yeah. They are.
Let's give it a bit of encouragement.
Yeah.
Let's see what I get pods shows us
there.
Same.
I guess let's describe and see what Let's
describe another Do have a preference between the
operator and the the other one?
Let's do the second one just because it's
in a in a container stage. So it's
actually beyond container create, and I think
don't know.
Do you think can get some
k. Oh, yeah. It's not happy.
Expected c groups path to be a format.
Blah.
So, yeah, it's still looking for this.
Can we just restart the cubelets one more
time on on that node?
Why not?
I actually did follow the docs for updating
to the the the system DC group driver.
So we might have gotten ourselves in a
worse scenario than we
started. Maybe. I don't know.
It's broken.
Oh, yeah.
Should we just validate that we correctly updated
those Kubelet configs and didn't fool ourselves, like,
have not saved correctly or something? Let's do
it.
Maybe we can can we return this to
system d and restart it? Just That's what
we tried. I thought we did. I've obviously
been a bit We forgot to hit save.
Yeah. Because the control play note, it was
was not broken when I left it. This
is something we
we have introduced
ourselves
accidentally, which is fine. It's more fun. You
said give me one job and I I
broke it.
We may maybe have to encourage those pods
again. I'm not sure.
Yeah. If if it's still screwing up, I
would maybe try to reboot the control plane.
No. That's not a horrible idea, actually.
Bare metal does not reboot quickly.
Oh, yeah.
Well, we can maybe k exec into itself.
That's a nice hack too.
Sure.
Yep.
But I think this should probably get get
it back up and running. Let's see. Okay.
There we go. There we go. Good. Okay.
So I'm gonna read the report forward.
Mhmm.
Do we think the Click. The test work
will help?
Hey.
You
you fixed it. Good.
So now do we need to try to
upgrade it, David? Is that I'm a bit
worried that I have reload, and it's
not quite broken again.
Yeah. It's finished reloading. Right? Okay. It's just
timing out very slowly. I have to do
the two second time out to that, so
that's annoying.
Okay. Let's check our service for
Postgres.
And we just wanna make sure it's got
some end points I guess.
It does. It does.
What was the error again? Was that
filter lookup address? Okay.
Do we as core DNS running?
But we wanna probably run a get pods
in the cube system namespace.
Is. Looks like it's running.
Maybe we should try to port forward again.
Oh, it also restarted once more. That restart
number is climbing.
Oh, it's working.
And I fixed the video encoding.
Alright.
Sid, go for it. Let's update this application.
This deployment is just named clustered? It is.
Yeah. I'm very confused why it's working. That's
funny.
I added another another little booby trap that
I was expecting to be triggered, but it
didn't.
It's fun. So we just want v two
on the image tag? Yeah. Please go for
it. Then maybe it will break now because
we update this. Let's see. Very curious. Who
knows?
Alright. We'll spend a few more minutes on
this, and then we'll switch. Container creating. That's
good.
Terminating.
Alright. Let's run get pods.
Reconfigure our port forward.
This looks good.
I heard that better tone in your voice
there.
It working?
Why is it working?
Why is it still v one?
Still v one.
Let's just edit again.
Did not take
it says v two there. Yeah. I wonder
if it Did it it bring up the
new the new version already? Yeah. In pot?
I mean, of course, when I was updating
the Is it maybe caching in the browser?
Wait. Is
that v two? Yes.
Yay.
That's good. That's good.
Yeah. Alright.
Good job. I didn't like that one. Well,
thanks for dragging me along there, David.
So you wanna fill us in on that?
On what what I broke? Yeah. Basically?
Yeah. So
I I am a vivid system d user,
and I was like, why isn't this running
the system d c group driver?
So I changed it.
And then I
which just means that system d is responsible
for managing the c group tree. And every
node in the c group tree is managed
by a system d unit, and you can
set limits
on each of the
c groups created using system d unit files.
So I
limited q pots dot slice to only use
to allow 100 megabytes of memory,
and this doesn't get reflected by Kubernetes. And
it's like, oh, I have all the memory
I need, and it keeps scheduling things. And
then system d starts
throwing OMs at the thing, and then Kubelet
says,
oh, this bot is in a very this
node is in a very bad state. It's
under memory pressure. We shouldn't schedule more things.
So Well, we've got just makes sense. Yeah.
Place, though. Right? Yeah. But I think we
kind of because we moved back to c
group f s, it kind of fixed itself
somehow.
Yeah.
So I I just made one change on
the worker node, and that's at this drop
in file for QPods dot slice in somewhere
in Etsy system d.
There's a Oh, yeah. QPods dot slice dot
d.
And this is the only thing I touched,
and then everything broke. So
so
yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
And I broke one more thing, but it
didn't it stopped breaking is that I made
core DNS points to
to the Etsyresolvecom
from the hosts. And because I'm a system
d
advocate, I changed
Etsyresolvecom
to point to system dresolved,
which happens to have the same IP address
as core DNS, which would cause core DNS
to end up in a loop forever and
crash. But that didn't happen, which was interesting.
It did happen yesterday.
So but yeah. So that that breakage didn't
happen, but
but the other one was
I was like, this much should have as
much memory. The stuff in the area namespace,
was that just a red herring?
Just a bunch of Yeah. It was just
me trying to deploy, and I didn't clean
up after myself
just to see if things failed to deploy.
Yeah.
I did make sure to delete the bash
history on the nodes so that it wouldn't
be obvious what I changed, but I forgot
the the the Arian namespace.
Yeah. Alright. So
I mean, there's there's a whole bunch of
stuff there. I had no idea. But, like,
I've never modified the secret driver because why
would anyone in the right mind do that?
Yeah. So it should it should default to
the system d one. It's just that's I
noticed,
for some reason, cluster API doesn't use it
yet.
There was this issue. I was like, maybe
we can wreck havoc with this. This is
interesting.
So
Alright. Well,
thank you very much. I hate to eat
every second of that.
The server lies about its amount of memory,
and there's nothing you can do about it.
Yeah. But now it's but now it's time
for revenge. Right?
Yes.
Definitely. Now I have to suffer.
Alright.
You wanna join our session? We are now
dealing with SID cluster.
Yeah. I see an active session. I click
options,
join session.
I will I see you typing. Configure
the bits and pieces that we need.
And I will give you the honors of
checking for an API server.
And the echo hello. Yeah. Fair play.
It's alive, but we're missing a pod.
This is right.
That is great. Do we still even have
a deployment?
We do.
Interesting.
Do we want to describe it to see
Mhmm.
Let's do that. What's going on?
Reload.
It says
let's see. I mean, the rep Oh, yeah.
Is set to zero. Oh, yeah. I'm also
gonna open the chat at the same time
so I can
steal hints from other people.
Just
let me move you down.
I think you need to scale this one
up, and I always love waiting to see
how people decide to scale that. Some people
edit requirements,
some people do a proper
scale up. Let me I'm gonna edit this,
I think. Yeah.
Because you said that word first and then
it's like, oh, yeah. That makes sense. I
could edit it.
Yeah. Somebody messed with this. Generation six. So
there were a lot of edits to this
thing. So I have a feeling there will
be more
more issues when I change this. But how
many replicas do we want? Just one? Yeah.
We only need one.
Okay.
That's scary. That was that was what we
needed to happen.
I wanna check other namespaces now. There's there's
a trap. Were you worried that that wasn't
gonna happen there for a second? That was
just that was my I I had deployed
something, and and there was waiting for that
to happen. So Oh, look at that. We
have Oh, I have the the
scroll
bar issue, I think. Yeah. You can reload.
It fixes it. Yep. Okay.
Let me try to
leave this page. Yeah. That's much better.
Okay. No. No. No. For me. Why is
this?
Oh, I I
already regret signing up for this.
I'm just curious
Alright. Okay. So let's maybe look oh, no.
It happened again. Oh, that's because I reloaded.
Okay. So
and will that now happen to you when
I reload
or not? Yeah. I'm gonna try Chrome. I've
never actually tried a different browser to see
if that helps. So let's do that. But
I think it's just trying to sync the
two sizes because you're zoomed in more than
I am. I think this is what's causing
the
Oh, really? Okay. Oh, no. And they're all
oh, they're all these namespaces were created, like,
ten seconds ago. No.
What did you do?
Yeah. I think it's just syncing the size
of our two windows. That's that's the problem.
That's Actually, resizing my window fixed it. I'm
gonna leave it like that.
Wait. So
is UUID is what you often use for
your namespace nameset?
It it makes sure I don't have a
collision I guess.
Oh, not a virus.
I don't mind not a virus pods as
long as there's not a crypto minor pod
too.
Oh,
it's why is everything so oh, no. I
have
okay.
David, how are we gonna get this out
of our cluster?
Get what out of our cluster?
The the everything.
Oh, man.
Do want me to delete all the UUID
namespaces?
Yeah. We could write. Maybe I
I don't even want to know what's in
there. I just want to get rid of
it. But I'm kind of scared because some
of them are, like, two seconds old. So
I have a feeling there's something nefarious. Yeah.
You're right. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. So I wonder if it's gonna help.
But we can try it. That's Well, let's
let's think about this. Right? So
we actually did modify our deployment. It went
through and then an event triggered it. So
I don't think this was a mutating web
configuration. Of course, we could double check.
But the fact that the edit went through
and we got a new event suggest that
there's potential controller running on our cluster, but
it's also watching the resource.
But why why wouldn't it be a mute
like, this is the first thing I would
think of like, maybe it would be something
like Because then because if we have as
a museum web configuration, we wouldn't have got
the scale down event.
I see. Because it would never have changed
in the first place. I see. I see.
So it's not something blocking it. It's just
something else watching it. Yes. I think. I
see. Let's let's check. Right?
Yeah. There's no mistake in my configuration. So
this is another controller probably running on one
of these names. Yeah.
Do we maybe want to Sorry. Need check.
Maybe want to check what service accounts
there are or like
Well, my thinking is, right, with the time
on these namespaces
is that the
not a virus workload will not be running
in one of those namespaces because they're too
ephemeral. So I think we should just stick
to looking at maybe
the five namespaces that we know and trust
and see what's running in here. Mhmm. Yep.
Makes sense.
So let's do a
why don't we do a get pods all
correct.
Running or something. Yeah.
That sounds good.
Okay.
We do have a couple of We have
not a virus which is running.
A lot of them, actually. Oh, no.
Do we want to maybe
describe one of those pods?
Yeah. Go for it. Scrape one.
Oh, but I need to know what namespace
it is. Right? Oh, no.
Okay. Wait.
I'm gonna open just scrape all namespaces pods
and then just that name.
Yep. Yeah. There should be one of those
pods in each UUID
namespace.
Paste. So if you I can do it.
Like, will this work? No. I cannot do
that. Kevin is looking for home describe all
the pods in one namespace. There's only one
pod in each of those namespace. I see.
I see. That makes things that.
So let's do again this. Pick one that
is running.
We pick our favorite namespace.
Let me paste it.
K.
So
there is a container called slash
clustered.
Indeed.
Do we want to know what's in there?
It's using the downward API, though.
What what is
downward API? I have no clue. A way
to I think something needs from the cluster
into the pods so you can consume it.
Usually, like, the IP address of the control
plan or or something like that or the
pod name itself. You can push down a
whole bunch of stuff.
Interesting.
So I So this seems like this way,
it's hooking into the the the Kubernetes API
somehow.
Yeah.
And we've got a conflict map called the
Kubernetes root CA. So it's actually using our
I would imagine Kubernetes admin cert.
Now
depending on whether we want to
I mean, we could delete that config map
and then those pods can't modify anything on
the API server anymore.
Yeah. I'm con so
you want to delete the the cube root
c a dot c r t. Well, let's
take a look at it first. But, yeah,
I'm I I think if we if we
get rid of it, it should stop the
the radius. Just want to know what's namespace
that config map is. Right?
Like, maybe it's duplicated across all the
let's just look at the
okay. So we have a volume amount
for this service account. Blah blah blah.
K. So here is the the weird stuff.
Yeah.
So it's using the download API to know
what namespace it's in.
Yeah. You'll have to help me here. I've
never seen this downward API volume
type. This is only Let's see how many
of these things we've got. Right? Look at
Oh, no. Yes.
Great. So
I want to describe one of them first.
Mhmm.
Okay. So It's
just It's it's there. Yeah. Right. Yeah. So
And I suppose this is the the server
certificate of the API server just for some
One of these namespaces
is
gonna be longer lived than the other sort
of ephemeral ones. There has to be something
running outside of these UUIDs or one UUID
that isn't as malicious.
I'm looking for a timestamp that's
let's sort it. Yeah. Let's sort
sort dash n on the Three.
Three. Right?
K three. K three fourth column. Right?
And then dash n for
yeah. This this works. Yeah. Good. Oh, let's
how do we reverse it? Do you remember?
No. I don't know.
Dash r. Dash r? Yeah.
Oh, but wait. Yep. I think you have
to put it on the Oh, it's the
key. Right.
Exactly.
But it's alphanumeric
sorting. There we go.
This helps. Okay. Let's just scroll up. We
can do it. Oh, no. It's not sorted
by yeah. You're right. But still, we can
get the longest running thing from here. It's
probably
three seven. I see things that have been
running for seven minutes.
Said we're no longer friends.
Yeah. But it all triggers because we we
scaled up this thing. Right?
Before that That was that was what I
was waiting on.
Because there's nothing that's older than that. Like,
can we look at things
okay. How about we look at all the
the different things and just look at things
that are younger than when you created the
cluster,
but not
from the past seven minutes. Right?
Just to kind of know
oh, there's nothing there.
So this all hasn't been touched as far
as I see. Right?
All two days, twenty two So
this looks
fine.
So maybe the thing that triggered it is
actually not in the cluster. Yeah. I'm I'm
starting to think about myself.
Yeah. Maybe we're we're
putting we're getting put on a
there are some red herrings. Lots of them.
So some something is missing from the outside,
I think.
Maybe it's the clustered part that does this,
somebody says in the comments. Yeah. We should
describe that, actually, and take a look at
the
image.
Yep.
That would be a good way to hide
something. I'll give you the honors.
I'm gonna comment much. We can just
so what is that container that we're using?
Okay. That's Postgres. That's fine. And the other
one
where are you? Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah. There was never anything running. So
it would be the Postgres one that's nefarious,
but it looks
like it is. Well, it's been updated to
take our
weird config map with the kubectl. This
looks like it's just a standard Postgres image.
Right? Unless what's the image pull policy?
I I haven't touched the post Postgres deployment.
Yep.
K. So why has it got the cube
roots there? Yeah. Exactly. Why does it also
have this volume?
That's interesting.
That makes me
suspicious.
Is that just always there, and I'm just
overthinking? I think it might be. Yeah. I
don't know. No. There's never a cube API.
This is
A volume that contains injected data from multiple
sources. Type projected. Maybe there's just some global
config that just gives it yeah. Maybe we
are on a Yeah. But I think maybe
I've checked myself or checked those here.
Okay. Let's let's let's focus.
Something has API. Okay. Let's try something. Okay?
Mhmm. The only way to access this cluster
from is from a vendor cluster or
from admin.com.
Oh, then we can't access it. Well, we
can't.
Protect it.
Oh,.com.Dotcom.
Yeah.
Well, there's also the
is that true, though, that you could also
use the Kubelet certificate
or whatever or the There could be static
manifest.
Yeah. But those don't look like they've been
modified.
But, I mean, there's also all these certificates.
Right? And I don't know where it is.
Etsy
Kubernetes p k I, which also all give
access to the cluster. So
Alright. Let's do
v coop.
I see You could look at the logs
of one of the not a virus pods
to see if it's doing anything, maybe.
Yeah. We could try that. Do you want
to try that? I have a feeling this
is a hint.
I don't know why.
So you don't want me to run this?
Oh, no. You can run that. You do.
Yeah.
Okay. Namespaces,
print the name, crap, so that we keep
cube root by default.
Let's not delete the default name. Oh, you
can't anyway, but still.
But I don't think you can delete any
of those namespaces except for the root. Yeah.
Let's just nuke everything.
I have a feeling as we're deleting the
new ones, but
it's like Hydra.
Okay. So let's follow your trade of thought
right now then, which was
you want to what? Sorry?
My train of thought. Well, I got a
hint that I should have looked at the
logs of one of these not a virus
pods. Alright. Do wanna So this fire log
containers and start poking around then.
Can we do that? Can we have multiple
windows hidden here or how does this work?
Well, I'll I've opened something on the worker
if you wanna jump onto that session and
poke around the logs there.
And we'll just leave that delete.
Okay.
I'm I'm just assuming not a various schedules
on the worker, but I I could be
incorrect.
Okay. So
so the nice thing about
I think doesn't container do you also send
things to the journal, or do we have
to go here? You need to go to
parallel containers.
K.
And then we no. I don't not the
container you're looking
for. It might be. So we can just
do we want to all of them, I
guess?
We could. Right?
Okay. It's running cube CTO applies. It's doing
stuff.
Yeah. Looks
nefarious.
Oh, it's it's a job. Oh, there is
a okay. That's
I think there might be some cron job
that's messing around. I think this is gonna
go on forever. Let's just do we cancel
it?
Get the
yeah. Look at this. And there's probably also
a cron job thing that's just spawning things
all the time.
No. Okay.
Okay. Interesting. But let do we want to
try to nuke I don't think that's gonna
work either to to nuke all the jobs.
It's probably
do we want to look at what this
container is doing? Maybe
Well, we got some we did get some
debug output. Right? So it's it's creating a
job. It's doing this it's scaling down our
deployment.
So this was reactive. Right? So this happened
because we tried to scale up the deployment.
Mhmm. It did. Yeah. So there's something that's
watching the cluster deployment. Yeah.
I don't know if if that statement is
true. It it is not running on something
other than the cluster or the two nodes.
Okay.
Doing Like, I'm not sitting here on my
computer running something. Just hitting enter every time
we do something.
I'll get them this time.
Alright.
There must be a Rawkode player somewhere.
So
Do we want to check
if there's maybe a process outside of Kubernetes
running on the control plane? We're just talking
to the API server.
Yeah. That's what I tried to do. I
was trying to filter out the
kernel processes,
but, apparently, I just thought that was a
rejects. Why does it think that was a
reject?
Do you think There we go. You.
Yeah.
The cube API server.
Let's see.
I don't see
a lot of nefarious things here.
Do
we?
It is not running on the control plane
node either. K. But it might be running
on the worker node. Who knows?
I don't know.
Do we want to check just to be
sure?
There's
a lot more running on the worker node
for sure, but that makes sense. Oh, look
at the sleeps.
Yeah. I think this is
k.
I don't think there's anything running outside of
Kubernetes that's of interest
from this.
Well, where are those loops coming from? What
was the root cause of this? I think
it's container d. So Yeah.
So it's probably part of the Oh, look.
There's a setup and run dot s h.
There is.
Yeah.
I think it might be worth looking.
How can we
dive into that container?
Can we maybe attach to one of those
containers and kind of look what's inside? Is
that a good idea?
Like, attach to one of
We can just cube CTL.
What's it? A text to run. ID. So
let's grab the
I was gonna say you could launch an
a new version and override the
the entry point if you wanted.
Oh, yeah. We could
Process isn't running anymore.
But
Yeah.
We I can try doing it from from
using
Well, we can just try control.
I was thinking of just attaching to an
existing one with kubectl,
and then
but we can also do it through this.
Yep.
It's fine.
Bar
run.
It
should be correct. Oh, without the container. Just
runtime endpoint,
apparently.
K.
Is it info?
Yeah. This looks all fine. Can we attach?
Yeah. I was looking for the
IDs of the namespaces.
Unless you don't have to attach by another
means.
We we can do it through cube cuddle.
Right? You mean the cube cuddle? To it?
Yeah.
Alright. So you wanted to get pods dash
a and just pick one.
Exactly.
Yeah. Thanks, Noel. That's what I was looking
for. Crack control exec. Okay. Exec.
IT. Oh. IT.
Pending pending.
Oh, and they're all jogged. Oh,
no.
They run for about thirty seconds each. Okay.
That's okay. That's good enough. Right? So we
just filter
we we we we can get this done
in thirty seconds. We just put a sleep.
Like, it will not if we are executing
into it, it will not
kill until we kill the thing. Right? But
these are things that run-in the cluster, and
I keep coming back to that first process
that ran after we scaled the deployment.
Yeah. But that They are they are pretty
much the same the same workload.
I'll give that hint. But was it running
in the cluster?
It was not. Yeah.
See. So
So the original thing that triggered it was
not running in the cluster. Does it Yeah.
And I'm assuming that's still running.
Yeah. And so you're so even if we
find a way to block not virus by
looking into it, it will just spawn more
not a virus after it. Right? Well, yeah,
I'd like to get to that first one
first because the because it's gonna be the
same code, the same binary, the same script.
As soon as we get to that, we'll
understand it more and then we can
thing. Now
on the worker So so what what was
the script called that we that we saw?
Set up and run. So maybe just
find
through the entire disk and scrap for that.
Just do
okay.
Let's
just
What is u d?
U power d is power management thing. I
think it's
to be what is root nerds coddle?
That looks NerdTTL
is the new That looks container DCLI.
Ah, okay.
But it shouldn't be in the root directory.
Exactly. That makes me and it shouldn't be
and this it shouldn't be installed on this
kind of node
by default. Right? So
I won't look at the bash. It's it's
empty anyway. So
root nerd cuddle is running. It's interesting.
But that might also be part of that
con wait. So
can can I try something? Please. Let me
just By all means.
Let's
see.
Yeah. That makes sense, but I want to
know if it finds it in other places.
What makes sense? Sorry. I'm scrolling my head
right now.
No. It's only inside containers,
but interesting. But there might be a container
running, right, that's was spawned on the worker
node directly outside of Kubernetes.
It's listening to everything
that that starts the whole the whole shebang.
So that's not
how can we find out all the container
d processes that are not pods spawned by
the kubel? All of the pods are Kubernetes
namespace for container. Oh, I have a way.
We can stop
the Kuplets,
then we can stop all the containers in
container d.
Yeah. What's card on that? I don't trust
this node anymore. It's dead to me.
But does it make sense if we stop
the cubelets, then at least we
oh, yeah. Stop recording makes sense as well
then. Yeah. I don't know why we took
so long to do that when we have
a road process running.
But sometimes you just don't text. Yeah. But
you didn't drain it. Right? You only cordoned
it. Right? Do you also want to The
cordoned does the drain.
Oh, no. I meant it to drain which
does a cordon. Ugh. Sorry.
So
that should just leave the demon set. So,
like Yeah. No worries. So now let's see
if there's still something running.
Ordering by dates probably also helps in this
view. And then
not the container you're looking for. Still running
thirty seconds So that's cleaning up there. So
I say we run
cry control p s again.
Is that liveness Prometheus?
Is that out of place? There's no Prometheus
on the cluster. Yeah.
That looks interesting. Right?
Let's do an info on that liveness container
ID and see what it is. Sure.
But it was also created two days ago,
which may gives me the feeling it might
not
be the thing we're looking for. But
Docker image.
It's part of Cilium, it seems like. Is
it? Is it or not? I don't know.
Oh, no. That's just the CNI I was
getting.
Alright. Let's see.
N full command
isn't ideal.
What else do we have?
I'm not that familiar with cry control.
Inspect.
Mhmm. Why did I give us a machine
with so many disk?
Or is that that's TTY.
Yeah. These are just all the devices that
are oh, this is part of SEF. It's
part of this. So okay.
We put.
Okay. So
the the there doesn't seem to be anything
nefarious running anymore on the worker nodes right
now. So maybe it's something nefarious running on
that.
I think so. This all looks fine to
me,
except that Cilium operator was created a minute
ago. That's a kind of suspect.
Yeah. There's, like
Okay. Let's do one more thing. K. Let's
see what energies we've got on this machine.
We did get the hints that it was
the same workloads.
Right? So Yeah. So it's the SIP plus
cluster.
Exactly.
A few versions of it. So
That was just me developing it. Exactly. Yeah.
Okay. So
o o three is the only one that's
running.
Okay.
You know what? Let's
Let's do something weird.
Okay.
Let's block docker let's remove the image and
block docker dot I o in DNS.
I was gonna fill it and actually take
a look at the script and say that
it might look Oh, yeah. That we can
also do. Yep.
That's if that doesn't work, we're gonna leave
all the other images intact, nuke this one,
and then make sure we cannot contact Docker
Hub anymore. Yeah. We we can add a
we could we could definitely block access to
that file.
I
hope this doesn't frame my machines that
oh, start Docker. There we go.
It it should not.
That's
Yeah. I I I don't plan. I mean,
I'll run it, but I'm gonna override the
entry point. So we should be okay.
That's the main you've been kind enough to
leave a shell in the image.
Oh, yeah. Well, there was a shell script
running. Right? So that should should be fine.
Yeah. Go on, Tucker.
Oh, it it's a private image, though.
No.
Oh, but we can get the the credentials
out of Kubernetes then. Right? So Yeah. That.
So
do you want me to So you were
very close when you saw the nerd CTL.
I couldn't get CryControl to work. That's why
nerd CTL even was in the logs at
all. Mhmm.
So we were we were close with Nerd
CTL. Interesting.
But why is it not on the or
why is it not anywhere?
Oh, yeah. It's alright. Need go ahead and
Let's just do
How is that update and locate?
There's lots of things.
For our lit nerds
CTL.
K.
This has helped me. There's lots of processes
named NorthCTL running. Okay. So I guess
interesting. So maybe those containers are running NorthCuddle.
No. It's still running because we stopped all
of those. Right?
So
Yeah.
Interesting.
So
we have
a lot of
there's a network namespace named nerd CTL.
And
how about
no. Damn it.
Do we
How is this okay. So this this is
our nasty process.
Okay. So we've got a process here. Right?
Yeah. We can do a process
ID.
Alright. Let's go in here first. There's
a way to n s. And this is
our namespaces.
So why don't we do an n s?
Do we have n s center? And then
Yep. We do. We can tell it to
enter the.
So we just give it the ID. Space
this.
I'll redo this again.
This is where we wait for somebody in
the comments to tell us. Just
to drive it. Maybe it's f, maybe it's
not t. I think it might just target
pet to alright. Okay. Did I just go
the wrong way around? So is it the
NS enter mount
Alright. Oh no. We're not doing pet because
we know. Oh we could do pet.
Okay.
How did I tell the namespace then?
Target.
Or dash m for the mountain namespace.
Mhmm.
Okay. So
n s enter
mount
prok.
No?
I can't remember how to enter.
I'm feeling Me neither. So we'll figure it
out together. No. That's fine.
Did we get a hint?
Thank you, Noel. I must have been I
I gave a hint since I think cleaning
up will be more interesting than continuing to
hunt. Yeah. Good.
Thanks.
K. So let's
did that not work?
Okay.
No. That's our normal host. I don't think
we're in the Interesting.
What was your hand? CTRC
list. Right. Okay. Let's do that.
And then exec into the container itself.
Yeah.
Let's do this.
Did that not work?
Because why not? I think maybe I just
got the wrong way around.
Maybe. Yeah. I think the IT comes here.
No.
Like I said, I couldn't get cry control
to work, so I installed Nerd CTLs
instead.
K. So we But then I deleted it.
I can I can reinstall it real quick?
I
feel like the andesenter should have worked, though.
Yeah. That was also a bit surprising to
me.
Just enter
a p.
I've not got a pet anymore.
P f three x grip.
Okay.
Yeah.
Null's always on the ball with this stuff,
isn't he?
I forgot the runtime endpoint.
I think you got it right.
No. We got an error.
Oh, so my container Failed to find container.
Oh, that's that's okay. I can fix that.
So
Yeah. But it's not yeah. But the funny
thing is it doesn't show up here. Right?
Maybe there are two
instances of container d running.
No. The problem is the cry control, I
think, defaults to the namespace of kit.
It's only shows that the Kubernetes pods.
I see.
So I I just plopped a a nerd
CTL binary into the root directory if you
wanna use that. Awesome. Slash root. There we
go.
Alright. Exec,
this,
and bash,
and IT.
Hey. We're in.
K.
That So what is what
okay.
So let's look at that script. Right? Oh,
there's lots of stuff here. Set up and
run. Let's look. Oh, there's a read me.
How about we look at that first?
How how how kind?
That's just my my notes.
But it there's probably good info in there.
Yeah.
Do you want to look at the
there's no FIM here. Right? No.
K.
Okay. We'll just scroll up. It's not that
long.
K. Let's see what it does. This is
a very nice hacker to leave us the
notes on what what he did.
So there's to dos that have been done.
Create Docker secret before port, protect against failed
Kube Cuddle calls,
Create a port which kills some cluster test
workloads, replicates itself and times.
Create a private docker registry image.
Copy
to worker. Run container.
K. It's on NerdCutl because you couldn't get
the thing to work. Okay. What
I think we can do, though, is just
we can throw away this
stop this container from running and then nuke
everything from the Kubernetes cluster. Right? And then
that should
Yep. Help us. But do we want to
know why it is stopping things from scaling,
or do we just first get rid of
the problem?
I think we should run. It's it's not
doing anything too intelligent.
K.
Yeah. Okay. Let's just get rid of it.
K. Good. K.
Let's now go back to the control plane
node, I suppose.
Right.
And then we can do your delete namespaces
command again that we did before.
This one.
And, hopefully, it should terminate this time.
Or does it?
Depends on many namespaces we have. Yeah. Everything
is cordoned as well. Right? So we shouldn't
have new things starting either. The work very
same. Cordoned. Yeah. K.
You're getting praised for your make file.
Yeah. If a make file, read me.
It's good good work.
This is taking a little hoping it was
just the only thing you had done was
scale our deployment to zero.
Yeah. Yeah. I was like, oh, yes. We
got it. It's easy.
We got this.
This tough to test without
having things go completely haywire.
So
I was I was I was very nervous
at that moment whether or not it would
actually work. Mhmm.
This is a lot of namespaces.
It's oh, you you cancel it. Turn it.
Yeah.
It's the number going down. That's the question.
Yeah. How many do we have? Yeah. Yeah.
Wanted to check. K. 3,086.
And if you run it,
it's going down. It's just gonna take a
while.
Well yeah. We have to get rid of
all of them first, I think. Yeah.
If you do dash dash weights
equals false, it might parallelize
it. Because now every time it's waiting for
the namespace to be cleaned up
before it executes the next command, so maybe
we can
Fire and forget. Exactly.
No. That didn't make it much more quicker.
Darn it.
We can maybe
XARX do it in parallel.
Is there a flag for XARX to do
things in parallel?
Can you use? I have no no no
idea. You
want me to issue the same command from
my laptop and see if we
No. I think it's going right.
Yeah. Yeah.
Slowly.
Is there a faster Yeah. I mean, because
that node is now cordoned,
none of those workloads should be able to
run and continue to self replicate. So I
I suspect that once we get them cleaned
up, everything will just work fine. But do
you modify the maximum pod limit on the
node?
Or no? I guess they're just queued up
while they wait on each other exiting. Alright?
The jobs. Yeah. I think Kubernetes make sure
that
it doesn't spawn all the jobs at the
same time. It queues them up.
Doesn't it?
I don't know, actually. Yeah. Not not familiar
with how that handles it either.
But I just need to wait another twenty,
thirty minutes for this to delete. Yeah.
But we we we we can do it
in parallel though, I think. Yeah. Well, let's
hope it or not. Let's leave that deleting.
Right? We're we're pretty confident we're not gonna
get that back. I've opened a new control
plane one. So let's try and get our
our deployment updated.
But we we can't encode on that node
probably until all those namespaces are away.
And we could edit
we'll add a toleration to our clustered thing
and just schedule it on the control plane.
Is that is that cheating?
No. No. I guess not.
Yeah.
Let's just try and wrap this up in
the next few minutes. I know we're a
little bit over, So let's see if we
can get through this.
Did you join?
Wait. One second.
I did not join. Wait. Which one is
it? The other one that, of course, created
a minute ago. Yep. I'm in.
Alright. My connection dropped for a minute. Hopefully
hopefully, you can hear me now. Oh, yeah.
Yep. We hear you. Great.
Do you want do we want to move
it to the control plane?
The
we can remove the no schedule thing from
the control plane, or we can add a
toleration to our
workloads.
Either works, I guess.
I
don't remember how to type a toleration at
the top of my head, do you? Yes.
No. So what I'm gonna do instead is
edit the note, the because then those jobs
make a schedule on it.
Oh, good point. So we cannot do that.
Yeah. Exactly. So I
I do. Let's let's key key k edit
the
control play note.
We can do it. We can do it.
Where are the things?
I think the syntax comment on is we
could have done x I x with a
dash p for parallel.
I'll try and speed that up just now.
And do p 16 or something. It's a
it's a very Yeah. We still got a
few to go.
2,000 or so.
Yeah.
Mean Yeah. Well, this machine has, like, 48
course. Right? So we can do 48.
Is this going faster?
I don't know.
In the meantime,
how
do I select this text?
Usually, I have a global buffer in Vim.
Now I don't know how to
like, it's actually selecting the text in in
Vim now instead of I I copied it
if that helps.
Okay.
So now we're just gonna edit the
deployment,
and then we're just gonna paste it in
the spec here.
And then we change the words taints to
tolerations, and then Is that it? Yeah.
I think so.
Oh, sorry. Off you go. I went K.
Right. Okay.
I think the Seven 1,700 to go. I
think this should help. Yeah.
Here we go. It's great.
We'll have to do the same for Postgres.
Right?
Yes. Correct.
Edit. Is that a stateful, Seth? It is.
It's,
again,
your turn to do your magic. Oh, yeah.
My magic. I'm the pester. That's where we
are. Right?
Well, you can do the rename. That's
your skill.
Exactly.
Do you need me to do anything here?
No. The tabs. The You've
done enough, Sid.
K. There you go.
We might have to Yeah. But I think
we'll need to do a little delete there.
Gotta reschedule. Because it needs needs it tries
to be friendly against stateful service. We we've
made that more difficult than we had to.
We could just have added node name to
both of those.
What is the control plan mode
rather than going through the scheduler. But
it's Okay. It's up, I guess. Well, it's
not ready yet, but yeah. Now it is.
Okay. We have it.
Alright. Do you wanna do the
do the image upgrade and then we'll do
the port forward? I don't think we need
to port forward to p one just
Yeah. I didn't really touch anything system wise,
so I suspect it'll work just fine.
Okay. Let's look at this version.
I'm just gonna for a little laugh, take
a look at our namespace.
1,200 to go.
I don't think that's gonna finish by the
time we wrap up.
Rule out deployment status.
Our status deployment.
Successfully rolled out. There we go. Well, let's
give it a shot.
Let's give it a shot.
That's the dance.
Nice work.
Damn it. Both of you. That was tough.
Yep.
Yeah. I like I like the the cordon
strategy.
My I I had the same idea as
Irian to fix it in terms of block
Docker Hub and and then clean things up.
Yeah. I I, you know,
I don't know if it's just, you know,
this sure or what, but it's it's it's
always so obvious that, yeah, we just have
to coordinate to stop this replication happening. Like,
we knew it was replicating, but still we
were focused
on trying to understand the why rather than
actually
stop First, stop stop the cause and then
investigate. Right? Instead of the other way around.
Now we've got ourselves in a situation where
we need to run delete for half an
hour. I I think that's the context that's
important. Right? We we know this is not
a real production service, so we don't actually
think about all of those other things first.
And I think I need to try and
flip that mindset in my head. Yeah. The
the card and
help, but
that was a pretty nefarious script.
That was So what did it do? We
actually didn't read it. And I guess the
whole API server thing was a we we
were just confused about some output that didn't
have anything to do with it. Yeah. Or
did it? Yeah. I mean, the the it's
just based on a KubeCTL container. I copied
in my credentials.
It pulls to see if the cluster deployment
has any pods. If it has pods, then
it basically flips a trigger and and from
then on, self replicates.
A worm. You gave us a worm. Yeah.
And so I've I I put it in
a container on the the worker because I
figured if I put it directly on the
worker, it might be easier to find. But
if it's just if you're just seeing, oh,
container d is running some stuff,
that seemed
seemed like it would look normal ish.
Yeah.
It was I thought yeah. I think
we knew there was a process, but trying
to find it was was pretty challenging.
Nice work, both of you. Yep. Very well
played.
Unfortunately, two really tough containers.
I'm gonna have to make sure whoever's on
next week makes it a lot easier for
me because I
We can then edit the deployment and scale
it up to one and then we can
celebrate. Like Yes. That that was it. I
need someone just to come on and just
do something really simple because
these are tough. Okay. They seem to be
just getting harder and harder.
But hopefully, our exploration is still providing viable
knowledge to to everyone else. And hopefully, not
giving too many people bad ideas for me
to break clusters. That would be unintended. And
and I do think that that will be
a side effect maybe. I don't know. Yeah.
I wonder how many people are gonna go
write their own little Warming container that does
self replication and bring it down the machine.
That's Well, so I I got the idea
for it because I I do some work
with Kubeflow, and I wrote a recursive Kubeflow
pipeline and it got out of hand on
me one time. And so the way that
I stopped that was to delete the image
that it was pulling
and then go clean stuff up. But
Yeah. I think our container d alias would
had a very similar effect there just to
stop it doing that.
I know we went over, but thank you
both for sticking with us. Thank you for
sharing your knowledge and horrible ideas with us.
And I hope you both had fun and
I'll speak to you all again later. Yeah.
It was fun. Thanks for having us. Alright.
Have a great day. I'll speak to you
soon. Bye. See you. Ciao. Ciao. Take care.